so hi my name is Ola have fun pres
promote wow
words let's get the stress out hi my
name is Ola have fun uh with that name
this is playing video games one frame at
a
time this is my
face this is my name this is my title
apparently and this is where I work and
if you type this on Google you will find
me I'm I'm all over the place I will
yell at the internet everywhere and you
can yell at me there's places on the
internet where you can yell at me that's
really cool uh I work at this company
called fact lines uh I was I talked to
marketing yesterday like can you give me
a marketing slide a thing I can show and
they're very boring very like Technical
and very accurate which I thought like
for programmers that would be cool but
basically if you work at a Norwegian
company and you know these words and
these words scare you Callum
I think that's the best way to do it
some of you might recognize these words
and if they do and they scare you that's
the one to call all right
cool so I've had a theme in the past
couple of years of my talks that I
always start with a philosophy quote got
to have a good philosophy quote so
people say that nothing is impossible
but I do nothing every day which is of
course the philosopher we need the
Poo yes yes yes all right so who am I
maybe for those who who don't know who I
am uh this is me when I was younger well
like Mitch hurg said all photos are me
of me when I was younger but I worked on
air traffic control systems for a couple
of years that's a very interesting field
to be in uh I was in the gaming industry
for seven years that's also a very
interesting field to be in but for a
very different reason uh I'm in that
photo if you can spot me you can raise
your
hand uh and then I was there we go a
consultant in Norway for a couple of
years as well which is why I'm here this
is me yelling at you and then you can
yell at me good so what do this talk
about all
right uh a good way to describe this
talk is it's a bit of silly fun a little
bit uh it's a bit of curiosity like
you've had these projects where you're
like I want to I want to go down the
rabbit hole I'm going to go all the way
and see what happens right uh and there
are when I went down the rabbit Hall yes
I did find some real life use cases and
yes there will be a slide at the end uh
that will will show you those use cases
but it's mostly part one and two all
right and I I asked you in the beginning
are ready from everybody raised their
hand so that's good uh this is also a
probably not an area a lot of people
have thought
about uh cuz I can see maybe not
everybody here like who's here as a
gamer like a gamer gamer yeah it's like
half the room so this will be very
interesting for your other half of the
room
good also this is a caveat for for
people who have been to my talks I did a
talk here last
year that was way more serious than this
one it was like about education and
learning and and how our brain gives
information cat information and all that
uh yeah about how humans learn
information and in that talk I said and
you can have like a cut unfortunately
like a old time video unfortunately in
this case there is considerable evidence
in many situations that this strategy
the one-hour
lecture is rather
poor lectures May Inspire this is from
71 by the way lectures May Inspire
motivate and inform but it rarely
fulfill the principles of effective
learning right it is certainly
inadequate for developing high level
skills 71 and it's been shown in other
papers and and tests after that so I
cannot in good conscience make a talk
the year after where I'm trying to teach
you
something CU that's kind of weird right
yeah so instead I decided to make a fun
talk
right so about some real life
applications they might not talk about
and also again there's a lot of caveats
here uh I will do stuff to video games
in this
talk yes uh if you are going to do
similar stuff to video games I would
like to ask you nicely only do this to
single player non-online
games right I'm giving you the tools
please be
nice please don't do crazy stuff like
like I'm not the police but be be nice
right you want the people to be nice to
you so you should be nice to them
cool uh so boring backstory playing
video games is great fun but I am also a
programmer right I think so someone told
me that how can I marry these two things
together and some of you might think
like well you can make games well I
worked in the gaming industry for seven
years so like okay cool then what right
I'm done with that even though I didn't
make any games I just worked on
games uh but what if there is another
way right there must be another
way games are just
applications so can we do something to
control these applications
remotely can we have some fun with the
games
remotely uh what are the different
challenges you will like if you have
this idea you say I'm going to control
games remotely right you will have a
couple of challenges and I will show you
it's basically like you're going to hit
your head and I will show you where
right
so and can some of this apply to
interacting with other software say yes
it can cool okay so now cat done that
took half an hour no no all right level
one since we're in a video game I have
to have levels right level
one what if the game that you would like
to play remotely or
programmatically just supports it right
that's level one that's the easiest
level they support you playing with it
PR programmatically so let's play that
game and that game
is yeah half the room is going yeah the
other half is what is
this so this is
Doom right Doom is a 1993 first person
shooter you shoot the demons in the face
everybody's happy
right and the thing is it's 93 games in
'93 were kind of weird for those who
were playing games in 93 games in '93
were kind of I don't know they're not
this this was a thing this was
revolutionary so they changed how you
think of first person game I'm in the
first person I'm interacting with the
world so that's kind of other games kind
of did that but this was the there was a
point in time where this application was
installed on more computers than
Windows right this application crashed
University networking systems based on
how many people wanted to download it
like this was a thing they also changed
online multiplayer because not only is
this a game that revolutionized how
these games work they also had online in
'93 which is like what
okay and game modifications because they
gave the specs to how everything worked
in the game so not only did they like
hey here's a revolutionary game also
here's how it works and people are still
messing with this to this day like
there's a big YouTube Series this year
about a person that that played with
this made a horror game that was very
strange if Google my house on YouTube
you will you will get that one and also
this last chapter video game
speedrunning which is a concept probably
even the fewer of you know what is so I
can't go over everything but I'm
actually looking at the last one we do
game speed running
all right so this is a human thing
whenever there's a timer people want to
be the best or the fastest right because
with the timer is my number is your
number all right I want it's as simple
as that right Doom is no exception and I
love the screenshot because this means
that someone went through the whole
level did not kill any monsters but
found all the items and found all the
secrets and did it in one minute which
she like okay but it's a it's a fun
screenshot and at the bottom you say the
game did it by default when you finished
the level it didn't say congratulations
here's the next level it said you did
this
good which is like no game did that
that's another thing that was just weird
okay so do is no exception because at
the end of the states there was a timer
cool and then of course internet is
blowing up so what people did was well
how can I compare me with you right so
this is a version of the game called
ultimate Doom these are the first 10
nine levels and this is how fast people
have been playing that game so uh level
one hanger in 8 seconds that record was
made in N
2019 people are still playing people are
still trying to beat this people are
still trying to be the best so again
whenever there's a
timer my number your number it's very
simple cool and you see a file over
there
okay some of these are from like 99 so
like is this a video what's going on
here like what is this file what happens
when I click on it well if you download
these files you'll notice they're tiny 7
kilobytes 5
kilobytes what what's that even one is 1
kilobyte so they're pretty small the
reason is that these files contain the
input that the user pressed when they
were playing the level
nothing else I press the forward button
and this this time I pressed the mouse
button here I shot clicked the shooting
button whatever that's the only thing
this contains so what you're then
playing when you play these these files
these are called These are called demo
files because they're demonstrating
something uh you'll you'll get all the
inputs so here's the header if you if
you want this is the header of the file
showing you the game version and the
level and what kind of version of the
game it is and some some Flags you might
set that might change how the game works
right and then after the header there's
just a line bunch of lines these lines
are saying did they press forwards or
are they pressing forwards or backwards
are they pressing left or right are they
turning how much what's the angle and
then the actions did they shoot the gun
did they open the door did they that's
it and then you have the next line and
next line right so there are software
called
XD and these are the lines
this is what you're playing and there
you can have the game on the side you
can have the files you can see all the
states of the game and then when you go
forwards a few
frames the character has moved toward a
few a few frames because they pressed
move forward and they're facing in the
direction 25 which is like the angle
they're facing and then I turn a bit
they facing a different angle etc etc I
move further into the level that's
what's saved in the file so when you're
playing back that that demo you're just
playing back that file cool right not
kind of neat but how does that work how
can you make sure that this always works
because this always works or this always
works again like there's you had the the
version of the game so there's like
probably different caveats to that so
this is possible because of one thing
and here's actually the they for those
who don't know they released the source
code to the game so you can go and read
it then yeah it's very 90c so if you
want to read 90c you can enjoy
that Doom is the
terministic
okay Doom is a single threaded
application where every entity in the
world map that you're playing it
patiently Waits their turn until the
game says now do your thing okay I move
one step and then they wait their turn
and always in the same
order but you might think what about
random stuff here's like some more code
if you if you're interested in looking
at Old code it's always fun so but when
they want to do something
random well there is no random number
generator but there's a
table with like randomest
numbers there's 256 of them and when any
of those entities they could always
doing things in the same order they're
very patiently waiting in line and they
say I'm going to do something random I
might wake up or I might do a different
animation or whatever they say give me a
random number then they happen to get
one of the numbers in that list and then
that index on the bottom is incremented
just an index and then the next thing
that wanted to do something random
they'll do the next thing right so
that's how random works in the game so
it's not really random but it's a game
so it feels random and that's the only
thing that actually matters it feels
like hey this is weird and
random so that index is incremented and
then next entity will get the next
number that could be you it could be
like when you shooting the gun the
muscle flash looks slightly different or
the how much of damage you do with your
gun if you shoot now you do 10 damage if
you shoot later you do 20 damage that's
because you just got a different
number and people have messed with this
where they Chang the game to all the
numbers to be zero so everybody behaves
the same way all the time it's very
strange to
watch so okay that's neat right
but what if you wanted to take doom and
convert it to
C++ so this is something that Jason
Turner started doing in a in a video a
couple years ago and then Patricia o
took over was playing with a bit more
it's like a this is like a NE thing like
can we because it's written in C can we
make it more C+ plusy right and this is
kind of one of those like forever
projects probably never going to be
finished but the question is I want to
convert it that means I'm going to do
changes to the the code base so how can
I move forward with that project knowing
that my code changes and my refactorings
haven't broken anything right so you can
play the game or you can write unit
tests that would be cool right but we
have the tool in our hands right
now so approval testing is a thing is a
methodology where you focus on comparing
the output of the old known bit of code
with the output of your new code so the
physical output
okay so it's more like a GI div the game
or application is going to spit out some
output data and then you do some changes
and you check out the new output data
and then you do a get div that's the
basic idea and this is used in Legacy
software where you have no access to
anything okay so this is useful when you
want to do a complete rewrite where the
original Source might not be available
or upus it or or some problems with it
so this is this is a great tool approval
testing so
Doom can run the old demo file and when
you're done running that demo file you
get a nice little screen that says we
played this map for this long we killed
this many monsters found this many
things right this is output
cool uh yeah the thing I
said so what if I play this demo on the
new version I did some changes I played
the demo again do I get the same numbers
like this because if the if I change
something about the movement of the guy
and then the guy walks into a wall then
he's not be able to finish the the level
it's going to take longer he's not going
to kill as many enemies so there's a
diff right I have old diff I have new
diff a new file diff right so and
another tidbit the game doesn't need to
render on the screen for the simulation
to
run Graphics are just a nice
representation of whatever is happening
the actual state of the game
game so we can add some Flags where we
can run the game in the
terminal so the game
runs and there's no graphics and I not
get the output so I can run this in a
like a Linux box that has no screen
attach to it I can do that that also
means that I don't need to run the game
at 30 FPS or 60 FPS like it's a game
from 93 I can run it as fast as I can
just go through it's deterministic it's
always going to do the same thing so I'm
just going to blast through all the
operations no sleep no nothing we have
an output
cool okay so the simulation is the same
so are we putting one to one one and one
together we can play the game using a
good known
version collect the bunch of output
statistics that says this is the good
known version output we can save those
demo files with the text output that we
we we
did you don't have to read this but this
is basically a uh a diff I'm running a
command line diff so I run the game with
no Graphics no sound no mouse uh I will
want the the stat output and I'm running
the the the demo so I run this on all
these uh all these demos and what I can
then do is I can run do many GitHub
actions on all these different computers
all these different in systems and and
64-bit
32bit because that's the so I know now I
did some changes I run it in cic run in
K of actions and here they took 10
minutes to build and if you can read the
the fourth to the bottom it's called
demo check it took zero
seconds and I'm testing like 30
different demos some of them are six
minutes long because I just run it as
fast as I can I don't it's DET
terministic I always get the same output
and then
yeah here's a some output here the for
those who play the game this Doom
shareware thing at the beginning so we
have the shareware wad in the KB because
you can't share it uh and all those
demos are from the shareware so we don't
have the actual full version of the game
but we have a the demo version of the
game to run the demos kind of yeah but
then yeah here you go all green and then
I can go and do my next refactoring and
change cool cool how I time I'm good
good level two all right time to level
up good remember I have 300 slides let's
go so what if the game you want to play
doesn't have the support that Doom does
right you can't just programmatically
mess with it like this cool
Beed who's played
Beed at onethird you should play it it's
very
fun so B it's a mat 3 game you have
these gems on the screen you pick a gem
you move it left right or down pick a
pick a direction and you want to create
a three of a kind or a four of a kind or
anything more than that cool you can
also yeah join four more gems for bonus
points and all sorts of fun and things
will explode it's very
colorful so after a match has been made
those gems disappear and the board falls
down and new gems arrive that's kind of
how that
plays
so we want to play p 3 automatically we
want to write some software that plays p
3 for us like we we wrot some software
that play Doom for us no we want to do
this now this is our next
project so step one what gem is where we
need to recreate the board we need to
know the
state plan two pick a good move do
something good once we know where where
everything is three move that gem move
it to a new location that kind of stuff
and repeat and then we can play the game
all right so project it's a super plus
cmake VC package project looks kind of
like this patterns and mouse and and we
have open CV so for open CV um we are
taking a screenshot of the game saving
that image texture and then we are doing
image manipulation uh because the game
is a separate process we can't touch the
game process but we can observe the game
process we can look at the game and in
this case we're actually just looking at
the pixels so we're going to look at the
pixels of the
game yeah and for those who don't know
OB CV it's a it's a pretty old like
real-time computer vision software has a
lot of support in libraries and all
sorts of extra features very cool so
step one we will we will spend a little
time on step one what gem is where oh
and by the way if you're in a big screen
and you run the game it's actually this
small but I will make I will make it
bigger for you so uh when you play in
this size the game board is 64x 64
pixels well each each gem sorry it's a
very nice round number right that means
that the start of the board the zero
position is at
26137 cool this is also known the game
board is shrinking and and and shrinking
and uh getting bigger from that
information I know where it cell is so I
know that the the white gem is there
that's the coordinates of that and the
red one is then 64 pixels in and the
green one is 64 pixels down from that so
I know that I just didn't don't know
what gems they are yet okay but how do I
know that this is the green gem right
okay so I started off simple let's just
look at the center pixel and if it's
greenish because I know where everything
is so let's look at the center one it's
like look at the RGB colors and like
this looks greenish let's try that but
there's a problem by doing that and I
tried that I implemented it it kind of
works but there's a problem if you click
on it it spins
so that doesn't work okay but generally
if you avoid clicking which I mean in a
game about clicking but if you wor
clicking yeah that that works cool so I
mean I have this Library open CV I
initially just used it because I wanted
the the image capture of the the game so
let's use it so they have a bunch of
stuff so I thought like hey let's be
cool let's use some like like uh what's
called template matching in in imv
because I can you can look for patterns
and images and do image recognition and
that kind of stuff so here's face of
Messi he's in a kicking some ball or
something cool so here's he kicking the
ball and if you can see can use the
mouse the the bright spot here that's
the closest match to what you gave me as
a template others kind of have kind of a
match because it's like statistical
analysis so things like kind of match
but that point in the center that's the
best match right and you have different
kind of algorithms or different meth
matching methodologies you can use and
uh yeah so there the the face of messy
is over there in the photo right so I I
give it this little snippet it says me
yes it's there and I'm thinking perfect
this is great so I created these nice
sample images of the gems right and I'm
using the master the
templates and here I have the game and
then I have an application on the side
that is the matching or or will show
show me where the matches are and here
they are the little green circles the
green outlines of the matches so do you
see the problem hands up for the problem
yes the the red one over
there yes and I have like this the
algorithm has like a threshold of how
like how aggressive do you want to be
with this matching and I had it at 55 of
some number and it didn't match this one
so I'm thinking let's change it let's
lower the threshold no
then after playing a little bit then it
matched this orange one which was kind
of glowing because it had like some
effect on it or
something that doesn't work okay but why
as a programmer you're like why doesn't
this work
cool so let's use open CV to our advant
no no I did that so because what they do
is they make it black and
white that's what they do so that means
a lot of the gems are kind of similarish
or sameish I lost the color info which
is the important
bit so let's go back to color cuz I
looked like the orange is there that's
kind of pretty obvious of where it is
there's a thing called HSV Hue
saturation value so I'm turning the
color stuff into a kind of linear
algebra problem where is the on the
wheel is the arrow pointing right so I
grab a 32x 32 Center area of the gem I
ask opv what what's the average color of
that Center gem I check that color
against
HSV and if you're in that kind of range
like if you're pointing roughly there
then you're green if you're pointing
roughly there then you're red or
something like
that and it's over there
so I went through and played the game
and I took the average values of every
single this took like two hours to go
through and get all the center pixels
and get the color information
and I made a chart what's the highest
Hue value what's the lowest Hue value
and a lot of them are completely
separate that means that you have a hue
value of 100 to 110 you're blue if
you're 60 to 80 you're green but you can
see that for purple and red which I
which is the one I haven't highlighted
there's a little bit of overlap and the
orange and yellow are kind of too close
right a little bit too close so WR a
function you have the HSV value when you
want to detect you you can also send in
the red green blue to do this
ambiguation so say like they are kind of
close but then if there's a little bit
more in the blue range then it is the
blue one if I'm unsure so the functions
I extract the values and I just ask if
the Hue is above 85 and less 115 you're
blue if you're this value you're green
if you're this value you're purple Etc
it's a very boring function but it's it
works that absolutely
works so we have this
beautiful now I know what everything is
and I can click on the gems and they can
spin and do all the funy funky
there's one at of course of this one s
case but I'm ignoring that for now
because step two let's pick a good move
so what is a good
move again initially let's do some cool
deep learning algorithmic la la la but I
just come off the color thing
so let's do something simple let's like
let's try this a simple solution first
so it was it was actually a pretty good
solution so The Simple Solution was
let's just play the game a little bit
and see like how the game acts and
reacts and whatever so I played the game
a little
bit it's not I've played it before so
it's not a it's more of a just a funny
screenshot uh and I had an idea and idea
was there aren't actually that many
moves in the game the number of
situations you have aren't that many
because now we're ignoring the color we
just need to find
matches so can we just list them map
them out and you can so I made a system
where you have uh you want to have ABC
but there's something in the way the x
is in the way so you want to get the C
from the X and over the X and over to
the B so you're moving the gem so it
looks kind of like this I want to move
the orange over the yellow and I have
the match right so this is the situation
I want to look for because I can do a
move and something cool will happen
right so I have a pattern when I have a
points so I have the a point and the B
point so it's a zero and the minus one
because the a point is a center point so
going uh backwards in the X Direction
and then I have the C point which is
then minus 3 I can call it something and
then I have a solution what do I need to
do to the C point to get it over so I
need to do plus one on the x- axxis and
nothing on the y- axis then it will be
minus two they'll all be together and
we'll be happy I can give it an ID and I
can give it a
value and I put that in the list and
here's a more complicated one so we have
like this corner piece and I want to
move the red one in so I have all the
points and then the last one is in the
push back is the one I want to operate
on what is the operation I need to do
which the solution direction and you see
that I have a value of three because
this is a better move I get more points
for this than the other one
cool and then I found out that there's
32 moves which is again a really nice
round number really
cool
so good but there are multiple moves on
the board which one should I
pick because this one is four and it's a
higher value than any others but what if
all of them are the same value which one
of them do you pick and what I found is
you pick the one lower on the board
because when that matches everything
moves down and there's more
opportunities for other gems to by
happen stands match just they just
happen to match because if you pick the
one at top only like three or four of
them move down if you pick the one on
the bottom like six seven of them drop
down so there's more matching that's the
one I say if it's ambiguation sort them
by Y axis pick the lowest one when we
move on
right cool that was step two step three
which is the simplest of them all move
that
gem okay the windows hdk has very nice
Mouse inputs so let's use
them and I basically want a function
like this I have the window I know where
to start because from all the stuff
before I know where everything is on the
board and I know where to go because
from the solution things I know which X
and Y Direction I want to go so this is
my function
so first what I need is because I know
where everything is in the game board I
don't know where it is on your desktop
screen right so I need to translate
that from use system metrics to get the
window and the get the scaling of the
screen and I need to I know where the
screen is on the desktop I use the X
Plus XY and then times the screen
scaling because you can have different
screen scalings so and then I've turned
the value from the game board value into
absolute value on your desktop screen so
then I know where to move the mouse for
that one cool and this looks a lot but
don't worry this is actually pretty
simple so I call that function to know
where I need to be
absolutely I move the mouse there so
this is just a windows Mouse input where
we are X and Y absolute movement let's
move the mouse there I click down the
button I get the absolute position for
the end end uh end position on the
screen I move the mouse there and I
release click then move click drag
release
cool so want a live
demo this your studio update ready
no let's launch this
one this should be the vied one I think
that should be the right location so who
who again pay to the demog gods right
good let's click play
yes it's found the special
move so here's the thing you see this is
playing pretty fast right uh there's a
200 millisecond sleep function on this
because it's too
fast I learned that you can match stuff
in the air when stuff is
falling it will find a match like oh
here's this white one that's below these
other ones if I move that one and in
some cases the game is like
sure let me fin the level yay there we
go cool
right
demo so we we prayed directly correctly
to the Democrats good on my own time all
right I'm all right okay I can be less
stressed for the next cool so we have
that let's graduate right level
three what if the game has none of this
right cuz yeah you can imagine a lot of
applications you want to interact with
they're not so nice they're not
everything is a cool little grid right
so uh there should be even fewer so who
knows this
game okay more than I thought for those
who haven't this is a great this is
called VB vbv as again a great name very
googleable um kind of looks like this
this was the nice little gift I found so
you are a character move around this
world uh you have these screens spikes
are bad and you can't jump but since
you're in space you can reverse gravity
so if you hit space bar you'll flip the
gravity so you want to do these moves
where you like uh try to avoid spikes
and do these things by by reverting
gravity the game isn't actually this
complex but this was just a little fun
GI I found of the character moving
around
so the game does not have built-in
support for just giving the game the
inputs like Doom has I can just I can't
just give it the inputs it does not have
a simple game State there's not a cute
little game board it's a lot of levels
things go all over the
place and it's actually fast-paced like
this is very like you need to be pretty
accurate with what you're doing you
can't just randomly just click the mouse
and just hope things match because then
your character might die and then
because in be jeweled I could make a
mistake it doesn't matter but here if I
make a mistake I run into the spike or
whatever and then game over so I need to
be pretty accurate
so this is what I initially thought I
was going to become hacker man
right again great great little short
film but I wanted to be hacker man right
but what I turned out to be is this
guy because the stuff you have to do to
get to this stage is more this and less
this right but it's fun so so before I
continue on with that Madness there's
one thing I need to talk about about
which for people who don't play games
might not know the game
Loop so games are applications like any
other but games usually follow certain
steps we get the input from the user we
update the state whatever that state of
the world of the game is and then we
take that current state and we draw it
to the screen then we go back get the
input from the user update the state
then draw whatever is on the screen
there should be like 50 asterisks here
but
if you want a mental model this is
fine again yeah what if there's no input
or we're not great at handling input
where it might be delayed or it might
miss input it depends on how you
implement it uh updating the game State
can take long like very long time and
that even can be multi-threaded that can
happen in a different thread and then
they just or many threads and then we
just pull from that state or the drawing
itself might be multi- threaded but then
there's a joint point where they copy
the state over and then they do the
drawing so you have that separate so
games in are in all of these flavors
right so again little flowchart model
you initialize the game then you start
processing the input you update the game
State you draw you go back back up uh
this might seem like repeating but I
need this I need this picture in a
little bit so this is called a frame you
see called a frame
uh processing inputs we don't think
about the time that takes less than one
millisecond less than a microsc it
doesn't take time how this long takes
depends it very much depends same thing
here it depends but if you want to game
to run at 60
FPS this whole thing cannot take more
than
16.66% you have to do it in in segments
right another way of thinking about it
is this needs to also update in at least
16 milliseconds because if the drawing
is Just Happening like that's just
pushed out of the way and something else
does the drawing because that can also
happen where you're drawing just Old
State or you're drawing um what can
happen is you draw half a state it's
called tearing like you have half the
state because the screen refresh rate
like if you have the if you don't have
vsync on you can actually get half the
state drawn to the screen so and we draw
this as often as we can so if we get
some code examples oh am I yes I'm
good get some timer stuff what's the
current time we have an infinite loop I
love those um so what's the time now and
what's the difference between what we
had and what we have now which is of
course in the first frame nothing but
let's imagine we've been going for a
while and then we have an accumulator so
we're slowly adding to that number how
long has it been since we've been doing
uh work I can process the input some
function whatever that is and then I say
if the accumulator whatever time we've
been accumulating is more than the Delta
time and the Delta time is the 16
millisecond thing which means that we
owe a state update we are in
debt so I update the game State and I
reduce the accumulator this also means
that if what we have accumulated is less
than the Delta we don't go in the loop
we don't update the game state which
means that the game State updates at a
regular tick but we might draw more
often so then we draw so that Loop what
it does is actually two things we might
owe State updates so if the accumulator
is like 100 we have to update the state
a few times before we're debt free or
the accumulator might be less than the
Delta time which means that that we
don't do anything but in most cases we
owe One update then we go we owe One
update uh you can if you make this kind
of application and you have an
application window you can test this by
clicking on the header bar and dragging
it about and releasing because that
freezes the loop so then you owe
time okay so this is another way of
thinking about this kind of stuff there
are as many variations of this and blog
posts about people arguing what is the
best and whatever but nice visual model
so yeah arrows pointing to the thing I
just said
great so uh the reason why I picked this
project that the few advantages this
project has it's open
source because like okay I want to do
this exercise on application I don't
have control over but if there's a
problem I would like to go and check
that would be nice just so I can show
you and if I don't have any problems so
here's the actual Loop ignore the con
volatile welcome to game but things can
be weird sometimes uh there's an
important thing in this Loop grop which
I then found is because we learned here
that update count might happen more
often so what I want from a game is that
we do one process input we do one game
State update and we do one draw no
matter what because that makes our job
easier right if you have the other way
around you're you're doing the same
thing but your job is just harder so uh
it's single threaded as well and the
game actually has options where you can
go and set the game to that value
because normally the game wants to run
as fast as you can but you can go in and
toggle these settings so then the game
will do one update one input One update
one draw always which makes our life
very easy cool so here's my
plan launch the game as a post child
process in some loader so loader game
process my
dll hook the function that creates the
direct X device
get the address of that
device intercept the game's draw call
and call our function first and then
before each frame we send our keyboard
inputs sounds like a
plan hacker man so here's the image
again so here the game is doing this one
at a time here's where we intercept we
call whatever the game wants to be wants
to happen fine let's let let you draw
but then we send those input puts to
Windows we tell Windows hey someone
pressed the key someone did something on
the keyboard um we can actually do this
here we can hook the input polling
functions but the advantage of doing it
in the draw state is you can then also
draw some deug
UI so that's kind of an advantage of
like because if you do it in the process
input you kind of can't do much else
okay good
so you might also think wait that's
illegal and windows thinks that because
when I do this operation did not
complete successfully because the file
contains a
virus or potentially unwanted software
but no I want this software even here
contains of virus or potentially
software here's the issue I can't run
this in release mode I can only run this
in debug
mode so if you have a solution to that
you can you can talk to
me so I use a thing from Microsoft
called
detours what detours does is help helps
you create these intercepts there's a
function somewhere I want to replace it
with my function you can use detours
it's very lovely it can get a little
hairy and how you do this um if You'
never done this kind of stuff before uh
you usually want a pointer to their
function wherever that function lives
and you get a pointer to it you create
your own function you can do stuff
before or after but at some point you
need to call their function and then
return the value and then you you have
your function and that's the function
that is replaced so the what detours
will do is it will call your function
and then you will call their function
that's kind of what happens here okay
and those who have haven't done DL stuff
this is usually what DL main looks like
uh and especially for detours you init
detours uh you have an process attach or
process detou so when the process comes
alive or not uh you do some in it you
create detour transaction and then you
hook your function
you need to have a transaction you need
to update the thread to say like Hey
we're going to do something you need to
attach the function and then on the
other side you do the reverse you can
unhook we actually don't do that we're
actually pretty or we I don't do that
but it doesn't M matter much but you can
you can detach things as well because
then once this happens anytime the
application wants to call their function
they're actually calling your
function uh and there's a library called
fra that is very good at this if you
want an actually library that does this
for you the library called fre FR fra
fr. re I think very good so and the game
that the vvv game runs Dix 9 which is
pretty old but it's fine uh I thought
like maybe there's some example code of
how to do hooking with DX 9 and I found
this it was perfect so thank you Tom
gascoin and if you're watching your code
is great uh so this was like a test
example I love the commit whoops forgot
to commit a new class just the latest
commit from 12 years ago but hey it
happens to all of us so this founded the
basis it my code doesn't look like that
but this got me going so this was really
good so this is kind of my main so I
have two things I have a loader and I
have the DL that I'm adding into the
game process so my loader looks like
this I have the name of my dll I want to
create the process suspended and I call
detours by saying create process and
then suspend it so I want to spawn the
game I want to create the game but I
want to spawn the game with my dll in it
and it's suspended so the game actually
doesn't do anything right now it's just
sitting there waiting for for someone to
Kickstart the game uh then I can start
the process and then I wait for it
forever and then my process quits so I
spawn the process and then I sit and
wait until the process is done and then
I quit when that's done so I follow the
game okay but once my dll has been
hooked into the game and the game is
still suspended I actually get called
and I can run even on the process is
suspended I can run so my DL main I can
call hook create
device and then I can call my little
function and do my little little
Wizardry so and I don't do anything in
the other ones because it doesn't matter
too
much and oh yeah and if you're doing
this kind of stuff mess message box is
your best debuging pal because you kind
of can't debug otherwise it's kind of
tricky uh and I can throw a message box
and I can get a Hello hook right so this
worked great what's the next step well
the game is going to create the the
drawing device at some point once it un
pauses so what I do is I create one I'm
going to create
one and I'm going to so avert your eyes
I'm going to extract the V
table and it's a double d word cast
which is a great one so now I have a
pointer to the V table for that object
and then I should release it I don't
care about it I just need to know where
it was right so now I have the V table
cool uh so I can I have made a little
structure that I can unprotect that
memory so I can say this is the pointer
to in the v table that I want to
unprotect that create device I just I I
saved where it was the function itself
it's usually at the same place so create
devices are offset 16 and the end scene
which is the draw one is at offset 42 so
what's the size of the thing I want to
unprotect it's D word what I want to do
with it I want to make it readable and
this is then this is the function I want
to run on that so I want to take the
original create device and save it
somewhere I have a function pointer to
it that's from the original and I want
to replace it with my function right so
when the game at some point unfreezes
and calls create device it calls my
create device yay so summary spawn the
game process PST attach our DL to the
game process hook the cre device
function so the when the game starts we
get that and then now we need to just
once the game does that and creates the
end device function uh create device
function we need to hook the end scene
function so when the game wants to draw
each each thing on the screen they're
actually calling R function okay so this
is going to be a little messy but it's
going to be fun this is the create
device function and it has some
arguments I don't care about these
arguments I just know they're there
because what I'm going to do is I'm
going to be a good person and create
that device for the game so I'm just
taking these arguments and sending them
in I don't care what they do they
probably do something really cool and
fun so now I've been a good person and
created the device for the game but this
then also means I have the device little
message box for for good good good
safekeeping I protect to uh reset the
the pointer that I did initially to for
the create device just to again be a
good person and then
I take that returned device that is now
our new V table and I find the original
nend scene function and I replace it
with my n scene function so it's the
same idea just with another function so
now when the game wants to draw
something to the screen they call my
function not their function so how does
that so yeah if I do a if I do a a
message box on the function I get a I
get the game screen up and running and I
get an alert on that one yay where are
we okay we're good we're getting close
to the end so here's the
function all right seems Seems not not
that great so far I call the original
end scene because I want the game to
draw something to the
screen I count the
frames and what I can do is on frame one
I want to send spacebar input on frame
two I want to send release spacebar
input this works this is like this works
perfectly and because the game is always
doing things at the same time this works
yeah so what I can do is I can create a
little more complicated
function that loads from a file some
commands saves them into a vector of of
commands and does that only for the
first in it and then I have a very
complicated file
format so a big S is pressing PR bar
small as releasing space bar uh small
Big D is pressing the D button on the
keyboard Little D is releasing the D
button on the keyboard so this means on
frame two of the game I'm pressing space
bar on frame three I'm releasing space
bar so I can play the game exactly one
frame at a time haha the title not the
talk and the dash is just nothing so I
can have like a wait timer for that and
then this is the
implementation read like if you're on
frame X and that Frame data said uh s
then call uh press space which is like
one of the functions from before just
the window send input of pressing the
space bar that's the whole
thing right so want a
demo right demo Gods take
two I am here so I want to
say loader uh
simple maybe not have the presentation
in full screen
here yep so I load that presenter
and the game now it's
playing and then some point press a
space I go into this
hole I avoid the spikes Bo
Boop and there we go play the game so if
I run this again like we talked about I
wanted to have some debuging
tools because I
have I have the render function so I can
put as sleep in the render
function and in the corner it says frame
52 53 54 and you you see the millisecond
delay of each so this is how I built the
file is that I know that if I wanted to
press space let's say let the character
go I wanted to press space here it's
frame 65 so I would go to this Frame 65
in the file line 65 handy and put an S
there very high technology stuff and
then I would just play it again and try
it out and try it out I can even pause
it make it go a little bit faster so if
I want to fast forward a little bit just
normal uh and then I can actually I have
the buttons here as well if I just want
to test it out but you saw I I froze it
and I like it's still playing the same
way it's like playing the demo file
right so I have a little bit more
tricky example and I'm going to slow it
down immediately so this is a puzzle
section very hard and I want you to see
a land space bar
there so there's a thing in games called
coyote time where once you go off a
ledge they actually let you press the
space bar to flip around for like a
frame or two because otherwise it feels
weird or bad let's go forward a little
bit
faster
here so we're going to land here and I
want to press space
bar good I press space bar very exciting
like who what's going to happen but it's
always going to do the same thing thing
ah very close right no press SP bar
here the next one is the best one
right go here down down still
able cuz the game is like no it feels
nice if you're allowed to press the SP
for a little bit later and I C the the
checkpoint and I can yeah I can play the
game so that works nicely I can do
normal and then we go and collect our
little trinket yay that works
um so for those who played the game this
will so those who haven't played the
game this will look weird those who have
played the game this will look very
funny so there's a like an extreme
Challenge in the
game where you have to like avoid the
Spikes all the way up do like a small
maneuver at the top and go all the way
down and avoid all the spikes and then
yeah so for those who have played the
game this is interesting but what this
challenges is uh this took me like an
hour or something doing myself cuz
there's so many I slow this down a
little bit Spike see the spikes aren't
perfect so you can kind of play with
them we have to go in there which is
some my way people never do and we don't
have a lot of time we have like three
frames to press that space bar button at
the top then you have to go and go all
the way down I think I I come close to
one Spike as
well uh there
yeah there you go and then and I made a
couple of demos where I landed on the
little pedestal there or I landed back
on the other side which is kind of
negating the challenge but it's kind of
funny so yeah oh and another thing like
for those who are curious I'm playing
this game every time and the twink it is
always there but the twink it is saved
when you get it I'm actually I'm
overriding the save files for those who
are curious I have all the save files so
that's why I can do this again and again
so I have all the safe files I can just
overwrite them this is how I can do the
demos again and again uh just a thing I
haven't shown in the the demo okay where
are we four minutes perfect so summary
games are neat and it's fun to play with
in
programy
uh when you have an application where
you don't have the source code there are
still ways to automatically interact
with it all right AKA and I'm going to
this is going to be yes you can still
test that old Legacy
application and and you can still do
kind of safe refactor to it as we've
seen so yes this was a talk about
testing write more
tests
right so we had all fun in games but yes
you can so if someone has an excuse of
like no we can't test the old Legacy app
like we have the the approval tests or
it's hard to interact with application
testing like you can write stuff that TS
a button or or looks for a thing on the
screen and you can totally do windows
interactions with it or even better
program your application so you can you
can do programmatic interactions to it
because it makes testing way easier
that's what the web does a lot they do
like interactions with chrome and and
that kind of stuff um so write more
tests uh if you're curious this is more
like for Curious people if you're
interested in kind of this automation of
games uh tool ass tool assisted
speedruns it's called there's a website
for that uh they have emulators for a
bunch of games so if you look at that
you can play and and see what people are
doing the the stuff I saw with the
spikes this that's baby games like
people are doing wild stuff to games
absolutely uh if you're interested in
Doom that we had before uh Doom speed
demos archives I had a lot of help from
them uh the edge cases I'm using to test
are actually from the Doom Community
they have a lot of like weird
interactions so I can put them in the
demos and then use that as the cicd test
for the the kup thing so they have a lot
of like weird engine quirks so you can
maintain the weird engine
quirks uh code if you want to look at
it's uh everything is on mine except the
last one is Patricia that's for for CPP
Doom um the first two I mean these are
weird like projects to prove a point but
uh yeah if you want to look at them you
can and that's my face again so yeah
thank
you 300 exactly shush
questions thoughts comments angry
runs a perfect talk okay thank
you